>> Yes, I hope India can become a superpower.
Or I would add to it, I would say India is
going to to become a
superpower with mostly soft power.
I think India's strength lies in the soft
power that we have.
And whether that's [INAUDIBLE] I don't think
India, like the other
superpowers of the past, of the past will
have that kind of hard power
because the Indian culture talks about nonviolence.
What we need to do is get a infrastructure
in place, we need to get a
more skilled workforce in place and I feel
most important is build up
the partnerships today between the civil society,
between the corporate
sector, and the government and the bureaucracy.
If we are able to do that, then I think we
are very much on our way.